bien cinq ans un cycliste qui roulait à
l'hiver dans les rues de montréal
après une bonne chute de neige avait été
roué de coups par un automobiliste un
patient comme il y avait beaucoup de
glace sur le sol le cycliste s'est vu
obliger de pédaler sur les traces
laissées par des voitures
une manoeuvre qui n'avait pas fait le
bonheur d'un couple princier derrière
lui après les insultes à un feu rouge
le cycliste a été rué de coups ce qui a
résulté par la perte de deux dents et
une visite à l'hôpital pour traumatisme
aujourd'hui les automobilistes doivent
composer avec des vélos à leurs côtés ou
au devant d'eux une pratique qui
augmente de façon explosive par alan et
rester en forme
mais pour passer un bel hiver c'est mon
moyen de transport pour aller travailler
grâce à l'engouement qu'il ya eu autour
du vélo à montréal l'été avec le bixi le
vélo a commencé à être vraiment
messieurs et sur la map
et ça a influé sur le vélo hivernale
quoi ya pas mal de gens qui sont remis
au vélo et que envie de prolonger leur
saison qui sont dit pourquoi pas le
montréalais françois des montagnes
avaient l'habitude de rouler seulement
d'avril à novembre mais il est
aujourd'hui accro du vélo sous zéro et
le conseil municipal a décidé de faire
une phase de test à la fin de l'hiver
dernier et cet hiver b la piste est
déneigé régulièrement et les cyclistes
peuvent bénéficier justement d'une piste
déneiger grâce à cette action de
de la communauté cycliste l'hiver un
réseau blanc de pistes cyclables existe
à montréal mais son accessibilité change
bien sûr au gré de la météo dans son
plan de transport de l'an 2008
il y a neuf ans donc la ville de
montréal avait promis de déneiger 45 km
de pistes cyclables
cette année en 2017 la promesse a bondi
à 1 429 km déneiger les pistes cyclables
n'est pas une mince affaire portant il
faut non seulement retirer la neige mais
les cols bleus doivent enlever toute
trace de glace le pire ennemi bien sûr
des roues des vélos est ce qu'on a pu
constater ya des priorités de deux
ordres d'ailleurs à copenhague c'est pas
compliqué à 7 heures le matin faut que
les pistes soient déneigées toutes
celles qui accède au centre-ville dans
d'autres villes s'est dit ok 3 cm et
plus on déneige 5 cm et plus sont de
neige mais il faut aussi prioriser voici
les pistes importantes qu'on doit
dégager priorité 1
voici des pistes secondaires qu'on doit
dégager mais dans un deuxième temps ce
poison dans un délai de 72 heures et
voici un réseau qu'on a des neiges
rapport la directrice générale de vélo
québec suzanne lareau
le principal problème c'est les bandes
cyclables c'est que quand la ville des
neiges la rue sa salle la charrue une
certaine largeur donc elles des neiges
un peu de la bande cyclable mais surtout
c'est que la mode de neige lui
s'accumulent sur la bande cyclable et la
mode mais je resterai jusqu'au
chargement de la neige
mais entre le moment où on déneige pris
en charge plus écoulé une semaine la
bande est praticable mais au moment
donné où on change la neige vallée il
reste une couche de glace sur la bande
cyclable fait qu'à la bande cyclable
impressionné pour plus praticable donc
dans les faits va falloir qu'on accorde
une attention particulière aux bandes
cyclables
alors ce que ça veut dire qu'une fois
que la charrue à passer de passer une
deuxième petite juliette des trottoirs
qui pousse rélève la neige encore plus
vers les voitures
ce serait une option donc ce cd
technique on doit affiner ça va poser
qu'il faut déneiger puis même dans une
passe et la souffleuse tout de suite
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut quand même
raffiner nos techniques de déneigement
les garde-boue par exemple sont des
accessoires très important rouler
l'hiver
sinon vous ainsi que les personnes
prêtes vous risquez d'être rapidement
couverts d'éclaboussures et de saleté
projetée par vos pneus mais la priorité
vraiment ce sont les pneus cloutés et
toutes leurs déclinaisons ce qui va
vraiment déterminé en fait la
préparation ça va être les conditions de
la chaussée on sait que les gens ont
généralement pas vraiment peur du froid
ça peut être adapter ses pneus en fait
pour avoir une à dieu une adhérence
idéal ça peut être des pneus à crampons
de cyclo-cross très simple ça peut être
des pneus à clous dans les conditions
les plus glacée et parfois juste avait
simple la pression des pneus ça va
suffire à maga lebron est agente de
liaison un transport actif chez vélo
québec qui organise pour une troisième
année à la mi février
le défi vélo sous zéro une activité au
cours de laquelle il faut braver l'hiver
afin de parcourir le trajet de 15 km en
plein coeur de montréal
c'est une randonnée gratuite pour
n'importe qui souhaitent essayer le vélo
à quatre saisons d'environ 15 kilomètres
sur les rues ouvertes et les pistes
essentiellement du plateau mont royal et
de rosemont la petite patrie
la réalité c'est que quand on se met à
pédales et on a très très vite chaud on
est à l'aise donc une fois que les
extrémités sont bien couvertes on peut
prendre beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir et
les avantages du vélo en hiver sont les
mêmes qu'on était voire plus d'espacé
plus restreint puis c'est un petit peu
ça qui est dommage c'est à dire que les
itinéraires balisés et protégés dont on
bénéficiant en été ont tendance à
disparaître en hiver alors on est obligé
de côtoyer les autres d'un petit peu
plus près mais en même temps tout le
monde va plus doucement tout le monde
fait plus attention
alors en général ça se passe très bien
c'est agréable pour s'arrêter pendant la
période hivernale
je préfère cela au à métro et bus c'est
mieux d'être c'était le plus vite que la
caf et parce que tu essaies froid un
reportage de radio canada international